good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Monday hope
everyone had a fabulous fantabulous
wonderful weekend we did of course
because we celebrated my birthday and I
actually read watched our show from
Friday and I was like such a debbie
downer
I was trying but the birthday blues are
very real I think the birthday blues
exists even when your birthday's outside
of quarantine and like a national
pandemic I agree did you whine I'm
having a good birthday because I feel as
though that you did so I had like such a
fabulous evening like we just had
low-key dinner at home but it was so
nice and we got to see baby Mick which
like honestly it's all that matters like
she was so fabulous in she really made
my birthday and because it was my
birthday like I got to hold her for the
longest when usually like we have to
share so it was really fabulous and I
ended up having yes a fabulous birthday
and I was really glad you know it's like
that's what we've been saying it's like
the pandemic and the quarantine has
really taught us like what's important
and even though yes I would have loved
to have like taken a trip to Vegas I'm
like spent lots of money at the end of
the day like I feel like I had a great
birthday because of what's important
that's family and that's unfortunately
not material items but I made a huge
mistake on my last what you did and I
think think you should clarify I made
such a big mistake Jackie and I were
talking I don't even remember what we
were talking about but we were just
saying how like I'm really a person who
values like experiences over material
items like if I have $500 and I could
book a plane ticket or like buy a purse
I'll probably book a plane ticket like
I'm much more I put value on like
memories and stuff and I realized that
saying that the week of my birthday
wouldn't like the ones I love are
shopping for a present for me was really
not probably the best thing to say or
the best timing because Ben um had
bought me a gift and thought about
returning it's like book me a safari you
know a year and also your friend Margo
was like I literally was gonna get you a
piece of jewelry but like I heard you
say it on the toast and like I was
thinking maybe I should like return it
but I don't know why the [ __ ] I said
that like it's true but like obviously I
still like gifts and use it like right
now experience your things like aren't
really an option right and I definitely
don't want to give that's like in a year
we'll go here
want to know exactly what I'm doing in
when so unfortunately material items are
all we have in the queue it's so true
it's all we have so you have speaking of
clarifications and purses oh we were
just discussing something that I think I
would like to share with the class
because they're some of the it's such an
old thing like I feel like there are
people who watch our show now who might
not even would you say that you know
what I'm I want to bring it up because
there have been a few times since I said
it that it's like I should have that I
felt like I should have expanded on it
no and I don't even know if I can really
articulate what I'm trying to say
because it's more of a vibe but it
haunts you and I just hope that maybe
you guys will get some clarification so
let me just get right to it a few weeks
ago I said on the show it was really
like months ago no it was
zum-zum era was um we were watching real
houses of New York it's when they went
to that big fancy house and there's Joe
Farrell Joe Farrell they're wearing like
their nice dresses maxi dresses etc and
a lot of the women were ran crossbody
bags and I said I made a really legit
stance I really took a stance and I said
there's a time in a place I don't know
if this is what I said but this is what
I feel there's a time to place for
crossbody bags and at Joe Pharaohs house
in a maxi dress at a certain age it's
that's not the time um and then people
like we're like posting all these photos
of me and crossbody bags and like that's
what I'm saying there's a time in a
place like sometimes you need to be
hands-free you need a crossbody it's
more of an athletic look you need a
crossbody when you're College hitting up
the bars you need a crossbody like there
are certain types of cross bodies when
you're wearing jeans and a leather
jacket you wear crossbody like there's a
time in a place for a crossbody and it's
not in the Hamptons with the maxi dress
at Joe Carroll's house that's all I was
saying okay well you said what you said
I said what I said and now you must live
with it
yeah no I just wanted to clear it up if
you're thinking about buying a crossbody
you definitely should I have a few that
I love it's a great hands-free option um
and there are some really nice ones out
there but just this time in a place
thing she says it's a time and place
thing to disagree no not at all
you're the one who's out here calling it
about mitts for that that's a fabulous
call I think you're a little kid you got
to keep your things on you yeah no you
need like your hairspray like a very
practical option very very sometimes
like when
you're at an event a clutch such as one
of the biggest developers houses in the
Hamptons yes I just like the look of a
maxi dress and the crossbody he just
wasn't doing it for me
by the way that guy Joe Farrell has been
in the news recently because he had like
a party in the Hamptons where like a
bunch of people got coronavirus and
Ramona was there but she claims her
knavery of antibodies Oh
according to Ramona it must be nice I'm
actually gonna get tested again for
anybody's after this cuz I'm just like
wine I'm bored I have nothing to do and
to like I'm just hoping I'm one of those
people like that's not how life works
out for me I'm not just one of those
people who like had it but didn't know
and they had no symptoms like no if I
were to get it like I would get it hard
that's just like my life and I just keep
praying that I'll go to the doctor and
I'm like you had it for a day you're
cured yeah but probably not but it's
worth a shot it's worth a shot good to
keep tabs always good to keep tabs
um so yeah I guess now we can get into
the news I had a really great relaxing
weekend I read a lot and I finished Real
Housewives of Potomac
I am Wow for the season five premiere is
it when does a premiere August 3rd
oh well that's like soonish well that's
fabulous I mean I had a fabulous weekend
as well because I watched a crown and
Ben was like during the week like I can
watch by myself but Ben like wants to
hang out on the weekends and he doesn't
watch the crown I made him watch one
episode last night he was literally like
so bored it's so not his thing um it
does look kind of slowed down in season
2 it's like a little boring
and I just you get so invested like
Prince Phillip like sometimes I just
love him and I really want him in the
Queen to like have this fabulous
marriage and sometimes I'm like you were
such a [ __ ] like you could not so you
don't support women like you're so
insecure and same with Princess Margaret
sometimes I'm like you know what she
just wants love and then sometimes I'm
like this girl is so out of control and
there's absolutely no grip on reality
and I agree with you you were you were
saying how it's like it's just so crazy
like all these things actually happened
and like no one knows about it but like
if you watch a crown obviously you know
about it like I just finished the
episode where like that guy wrote like a
scathing critique I've heard she invited
him to the yeah Palace and like took his
advice which is like so something I
would do um and I actually loved that
and like that's just a crazy thing that
happened you know yeah and how do they
know all this stuff
um I think from account like borough
biographers like private secretaries
like
people writing tell-alls and I think
also eventually like when it comes to
things that happen so far in the past
I think the crown is kind of open about
it mm-hmm so I I'm glad that you're
watching and that you're enjoying it
it's very educational
I feel very small and I keep walking
around the house talking like this and
it's impossible to stop is the illegal
no he's jealous of the other queen in
the house you know he's like the
number-one queen he is oh my god I also
by the way I got Jackie this is not an
ad but I talk about it so much I got
Jackie and Zak hooked on the beverage
that I take before bed some sleep you
get took one last night I had literally
the most amazing dreams and I slept so
good I'm obsessed with this product it's
so genius because I've been having so
much trouble sleeping in quarantine and
it's really helped me has you've made my
husband addicted no I don't mean
literally call me at 11:00 p.m. he's
like it's like he said can I get two
that sounds like some cans can I come
over I'm like yeah sure come and he
literally went to my house and got some
sleep cans yeah no he's truly addicted
but it's good stuff he's good time so
I've been sleeping actually really well
I slept a lot this weekend which was
fabulous loved his hear it and I had
been really overusing the word fabulous
like I I just can't stop
I mean it's pertinent to the situation
so what else are you expected to say
exactly I'm reluctant to jump into the
fast five because some of the stories
are so [ __ ] sad I agree but we are
gonna recap our movie of the week which
was the color of friendship and we're
gonna sign our new movie so that'll be
at the TV recap segment which I'm really
excited to talk about excited to talk
about the color friendship so yeah I
guess I guess the sooner we jump in the
sooner we can jump out yeah we have
obviously some very sad news but we also
have some exciting focus so without
further ado it is time for the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast fabulous fabulous okay
first story very sad news to wake up to
this morning Kelly Preston dies of
breast cancer at 57 quote she was a
bright beautiful and loving soul quote
on the morning of July 12 2020 Kelly
Preston ador'd wife and mother passed
away following a two-year battle with
breast cancer a family representative
tells people exclusively choosing to
keep her fight private she had been
undergoing medical treatment for some
time supported by her closest family and
friends the
rep says she was a bright beautiful and
loving soul who cared deeply about
others and who brought life to
everything she touched her family asks
for your understanding of their need for
privacy during this time Preston is
survived by her husband john travolta
and their children daughter Ella 20 and
nine-year-old son Benjamin their son
Jett died at age 16 in January 2009 but
that story it was so crazy and like you
just think like this family can't
possibly go through any more like Souris
and here we are I mean I can't I had no
idea she was sick and I just I like
loved her she said you love her she's in
like every movie that I love yeah and to
be honest like I rolled over this
morning at like 7:00 and I wasn't wake
up till like 8:30 and I saw the
notification on my phone and like it
looked Joel to me and I was up for the
morning like it was just it's such it's
so sad it's such a sad story and
shocking yeah shocking I guess they had
been keeping all of this private for
years I just it's so sad it's so sad um
cancers a little [ __ ] and she was in
the last song oh yeah she was Miley's
mom yeah she's in everybody girl wants
is the iconic role that I can recall Oh
what I recall is that fabulous Quentin
Paltrow movie where their flight
attendant in the air up in the air but
she places a nice split friend right oh
yes she plays the one who like doesn't
she like gives up on the flight
attendant stop in like the beginning of
the movie she's not the cheater
no that's christina applegate yeah an
iconic film Wow
no she just has like a really um
accomplished fabulous career and she has
two beautiful children who is just so
sad and I'm like really just this is
devastating and this is just something
like just like deaf sometimes just like
blindsides EO you know yeah definitely I
haven't thought about Kelley president
so long that she's been going through
this difficult time yeah
terrible terrible well we're thinking of
her family yeah praying for them also an
update in Naya Rivera story um Naya
Rivera texts to a relative may provide
crucial clue about for her final moments
the missing glee actress my Rivera sent
a photo to a relative's shortly before
vanishing on a southern
California Lake that may provide an
important clue about her final moments
according to a report Rivera took a
photo of her four year old son
Josie near a cove on Lake Piru about
ninety minutes to two hours before he
was found alone on a rented boat Us
Weekly reported what we found where that
Cove was Robert Inglis of the Ventura
County Sheriff's Office
search-and-rescue team told the outlet
search crews used the background of the
photo and the place where the boat was
located to help zero in on where the
actress might have gone missing Inglis
said quote we did send our dye members
to those two locations and search those
extensively he told the outlet he added
that in many cases there are witnesses
who see someone jumping off a boat so
you know which area to search and we can
find the body more quickly but
authorities said there are no witnesses
in Rivera's case there's so many things
about this story that like are freaking
me out the first is like it's a lake I I
mean I guess it's big but I feel like it
shouldn't be that hard to find her if
she's in there you know what I mean well
from what we said what we reported on
last week there's a lot of Danny in the
lake I think like probably I don't know
nature stuff where it's hard even for
the divers they can't just like swim
through him through they have to be
really careful and I think it slows down
the process and then the other thing
that's so devastating about this whole
story aside from the fact that like it's
just like the craziest thing ever is I
feel like the media is so out of control
like I have seen the most invasive
paparazzi pictures of her husband and
her mom like literally it's so [ __ ]
rude and disrespectful and it really
like blows my mind like just when you
think like the media can't get any lower
and like less caring of humanity like I
just see these pictures of her mom on a
dock sobbing like leave this [ __ ]
woman alone she's not famous she's going
through such a hard time I saw her
ex-husband is being paparazzi in like
private moments it's so [ __ ] rude and
the kid too it's like stop when where do
we draw the line I'm so sick it reminds
me of when Bethenny was burying Dennis
and literally a few paparazzi followed
her to the burial which was a private
burial they have these pictures of her
sobbing and it's just it's awful and it
makes it like an already tough situation
like even more tough and even it's a
such animation of privacy and it's so so
disrespectful it's
disrespect well I really would have
hoped that as a society we were like
about that I haven't seen those photos
that's so disappointing to hear and not
acceptable we're not involved we're not
about but um and like people like just
fans of Glee and just fans of and I are
like trying to organize like search
parties themselves on foot which is so
dangerous because it's obviously like a
tumultuous lake and like you don't want
to make it more difficult for first
responders so if you are thinking about
going I would suggest not oh I didn't
realize that that was being discouraged
well and now like um like the local
sheriff's departments are encouraging
people to please stay home like because
it makes it worse okay Wow yeah yeah
okay well we'll keep you posted on the
story still praying still praying for a
miracle
praying for a miracle okay into some
exciting news the new Sports Illustrated
Swimsuit Issue 20/20 is here and we have
our cover girls are you ready for it
I'm ready Kate Bach Jasmine Sanders aka
golden Barbie who he stand and loves him
and Olivia culpo
you guys she did it she did it she did
it she did it I mean this is this is
like a very Instagram friendly cover and
I feel like that was the five girls
these are like this is the Sports
Illustrated digital like Instagram
edition and it's so fabulous and I think
it's I'm like so happy for Olivia culpo
and these other girls I just think I
mean they look sickening so that each of
their own individual covers and then
there's a cover of the three of them
which is kind of like the one that's
going around but it's just it's so
exciting I mean devastating and shocked
that it wasn't me but again there's
always next year
there's always next year you said it's a
you know if you haven't seen the cover
yet google it check it out cuz it's
really like these are the snatchers i
also weirdly love the bathing suits that
they're wearing I feel like Sports
Illustrated isn't usually about the
bathing suits themselves but I just love
every cut of each of them I love how
they work together and I love I really
like the cover you know sports I haven't
heard other people's opinions yet so I
don't know if it's like a big cover I
didn't even hear about it I know I just
when I was looking for stories I saw it
and they were like Olivia Cobo shares
the cover them and then I
went to her Instagram there's nothing
there but there was nothing there so I
can't believe I didn't see but I'm glad
that we're seeing it because it's always
exciting the cover is always exciting
you know and there's so much sport
Illustrated news happening this weekend
because they announced one of their
first transgender models valentina
sampaio which I don't know if she's
related to the other to some payos but
there's so many some heyo in the
industry yeah and I don't think any of
them are related which is so funny and I
just I love Sports Illustrated and I
honestly only have good things to say
about them as a brand and you know it's
not the same but you I always I can't
help but compare them to Victoria's
Secret which is literally doing like the
least at all times and it's just like
the least empowering place for women and
if you like Sports Illustrated it does
everything right and this is a fabulous
cover at fabulous things coming out of
Sports Illustrated and we have
absolutely no choice but to stand
respect and support yes so a few of the
details Sports Illustrated Swimsuit
Issue just revealed their 20/20 cover
starring Olivia culpo Jasmine Sanders
and Kate Bach former Miss Universe COPO
who's been shacked up with her boyfriend
Carolina Panthers running back Christian
McCaffrey in Colorado but now they moved
back to LA and at one point his mom was
there but now she went back home because
she posted yesterday that she missed her
quarantine
also Christian Olivia got a dog so like
they're making steps they're in this for
the long haul
she said she pop champagne and got a
little emotional when she heard the news
that she landed the cover quote this is
still so exciting for me the 28 year old
influencer who's been in the mag three
years now in a row tells the post I
created a vision board years ago to get
into the magazine scoring a spot on the
cover which was shot in Bali by
photographer you decide back in November
is likely also a dream come true for
Sanders also if you saw model squad you
know that like Olivia's first time
shooting with you tie was just
not dramatic it was quite traumatic so
she's really come so far I mean you know
I really hope that they do one of those
reveal videos where we get to see like
Olivia jasmine everyone's reaction to
them getting on the cover because
honestly like that video of Camilla
kostik finding out that she was on the
covers like one of my favorite things I
could watch it like a million times and
it's so cute it's like so many of these
girls is like biggest dreams yeah true
and I love those like reveal video so I
even though we're in quarantine like I
really hope we get reveal videos I hope
so too also interesting factoid Jasmine
Sanders who goes by Golden Barbie she
said that she didn't make the cut for
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show
20:18 but she missed a but she was 2019
SI swimsuit Rookie of the Year and now
she graces the front page so it goes
back to what you said like one of these
things is it and the other aim and happy
to see it one of these things is that is
whatever you just said it was perfect I
thought it's actually not eloquent at
all one of those things is it and the
other isn't so true I mean that like put
it on my tombstone marry me
yeah so this is just like this is always
exciting no that's that's really cute I
really like all these girls and I'm
really happy for them yeah and I I feel
as though like being on the cover of
Sports Illustrated is a big deal you
know we'll open a lot of doors so we're
ready to see where these three go like
how we can take their stars to even new
heights you know what is your favorite
um Sports Illustrated cover like in
recent memory
I love the Kate Upton cover too because
I just love this I love those titties
like not to objectify her I know she's
so much more than that she's a model
she's an a mom she's an entrepreneur but
like she like well it's also because
like she has very large natural breasts
like which we both do mm-hm
and I see myself in the rug yeah I mean
I love this cover I don't see myself in
this cover no in 2020 but like I saw a
bit of myself in that cover and she did
it what not once but twice yeah but that
one where like her boobs are like
literally falling out of the bathing
suit like that's the best one yeah I
feel like that Hannah Davis Jeter one
where like her vagina oh yeah also
fabulous yeah I mean it's always a good
cover always this is no exception
oh also the Chrissy Teigen Nina Agdal
one is also fabulous yeah there's a
third person there but I can't remember
yeah but it's like everyone in there
like tissues true perhaps like this is
like the 20/20 version of that right and
now these girls will just be cast by
rock you know to me like these are the
biggest stars in the world Olivia culpo
and Jeff Sanders but I'm really happy
for I'm happy for all of them before we
dive into the fifth and final is that
what we're up to to the fourth and four
theists oh wow that was like so fast
well slow if you got whatever um may I
please for all all of our sakes we need
to avoid crowds any way we can right now
but what if you need to go to the post
office
what if you need postage to send out
letters and packages don't worry stamps
comm is here to help with stamps calm
you can print
on demand and skip those lines and
crowds at the post office plus you can
actually save some money with discounts
that you can't even get at the post
office and if that wasn't enough stamps
calm also offers UPS services with
discounts up to 62 percent off and no
UPS residential surcharges Sam's comm
brings all the services of the US Postal
Service right to your computer and the
safety and comfort of your own home
office or anywhere else who are
hunkering down right now whether you're
a small business sending out invoices
and online sellers shipping out products
or you're just working from home and
need to mail stuff
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
and of course starting quarantine we
should all be staying in as much as
possible but I think even after
quarantine nobody really wants to go to
the post office so stamps calm is a an
absolute staple in your portfolio simply
use your computer to print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter and package
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send once your mail is ready just leave
it for your mail carrier schedule a free
package pick up or drop it in the
mailbox no human contact is required
it's that simple and like we said with
stamps calm you can get great discounts
to five cents off of every first-class
stamp and up to 62 percent off shipping
rates stamps calm is a no-brainer
especially now saving you time and money
and keeping you safe during these crazy
times
right now our listeners will get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps calm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in toast
again that's stamps calm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in toast for a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
without any long-term commitment stay
safe everyone with stamps.com
love it ok fourth story a little happy
couple news Brooklyn Beckham is engaged
to girlfriend now fiance Nicola Peltz
this is crazy the happy couple confirm
their exciting news and a pair of
matching social media posts on Saturday
hours after reports about their
engagement first began circulating
online quote two weeks ago I asked my
soul mate to marry me and she said yes
Brooklyn wrote alongside a romantic
engagement snap of the pair which also
showed off the Transformers actresses
stunning diamond sparkler
he said I'm happy I'm the luckiest man
in the world I promise to be the best
husband and the best daddy one day I
love you baby
xx how old are they I know that
but exactly what I was looking for you
know he's 21 okay
and she is 25 okay
I mean I guess that's not that crazy
like Ben and I were 21 and 23 like they
were it's like 18 years old but to me
like they are yeah but they're not and
you know what I saw this and then I
really went down a rabbit hole of
stalking them because they're a couple I
honestly did wasn't aware that they were
even dating
yeah um to be quite honest the only real
thought I how about her is like when
Bella Thorne said that like she was a
mean girl and did that whole interview
about her and like yeah I can't get that
out of my head yeah but then I started
to go down this rabbit hole and like
they live a very like fabulous happy
life together that's the thing it's like
they're so fabulous and I think the
reason why everyone ourselves included
like regards them as such children it's
because they're both just like famous
kid famous people's kids
yeah so obviously it's like professional
kid Brooklyn is victoria and David
Beckham's kid and Nicola Peltz his dad
is like some rich man who am i there is
a fire alarm do you think there's a fire
in the building oh my god this is
bringing me back to the morning breath
days but Mormont's use to happen all the
time
oh and this also used to happen at the
beginning of the toasts when your burnt
toast yeah I mean I think we're fine
nobody seems to be alarmed in the
hallway well let you know if we start to
smell something yeah something but I
think we're fine nobody like everyone
else would be running out of there right
right right I don't know this is a good
new building for us I don't know it's
like these are things that happen all
the time yeah this is something to be
taken seriously I feel like it's fine um
yeah so they're both like professional
kids like they're just like stars of hot
like of course yes I guess you could say
they're accomplished in their own way
but at the end of the day they're just
like famous people's kids and that's why
I think of them as like just like
permanent 15 year olds yes but they are
older and I miss talking that I did was
really enjoyable I think I even gave her
a follow because Wow premium content
great flow she has like there's just
like very and the words not really
tumbler II anymore but they are very
like they have a like aesthetic about
boho vibe you know I just feel like oh
my god there's an announcement like
don't you know that Brooklyn and Nicole
it just kind of we what do they say oh
god I feel like he's saying it's a test
yeah that doesn't sound like an
emergency he was gonna have a real
urgency in his voice quite right
ya know I feel like it's fine it sounds
kind of cute I wonder if he's single for
snitch oh my god
okay well this engagement suite I can't
wait
she the dress that she was wearing by
the way the picture that they posted
it's just like laughing I believe the
dresses Victoria Beckham which gives me
hope that her wedding dress will be by
Victoria that's so crazy it's just like
I love yeah that's just like a fabulous
family to marry into the whole thing is
beyond fabulous like it was fabulosity
obviously like too fabulous for us yeah
agreed agreed
this and final story a little sad couple
news a couple I've forgotten about but I
did have a ship in them for the port and
now I have to break down Bill Hader and
Rachel Bilson had reportedly split
I wasn't like dying for them I'm not
gonna lie I just like I liked it I
didn't think about it again I I didn't I
don't think I felt like so confident
that like they were gonna go the
distance but I was hopeful like to me
Bill hader's just not like they
obviously haven't seen trainwreck enough
no no I haven't liked it that movie did
wonders for him but it didn't take him
all the way for me I just like like
she's so cute and cool and everything of
the sort so I just liked you know it's
it was humbling spare yes cute he's
obviously funny he's attractive okay I
really I would not say that yes of
course though they just made their red
carpet debut a couple as a couples just
seven months ago they are now
splitsville they're telling people
magazine multiple resources told people
that the split was amicable though reps
are remaining mum I'm the issue oh well
I read another I read and I read in a
different article that she was
devastated by the name really I did
actually
is he a heartbreaker I kind of feel like
a little heartbreaker I kind of feel
like he could be don't you feel that no
I could feel that I don't see him in the
way that you do no I don't see him at
all
even though hey man that movie
trainwreck like really was sensational
like he was so cute you know and he was
like yeah yeah okay those were the past
backstories and you didn't need to know
them and they were pretty fast
they were pretty fast we're pretty
expeditious about it um now our TV recap
segment we are going to be covering the
color of friendship which was our toast
movie of the week and boy am i glad that
we chose it boy am I glad that we chose
it that we watched it it was so much
better than I remember I barely remember
it we came out in the year 2000 so 20
years ago I saw it I was six years old I
was eight years old and better than I am
and I expect him and I was like oh I'm
gonna watch like the Disney Channel
movie that's about race you know D comes
really don't age well like I recently
watched smart house and it was a piece
of [ __ ] I'm sure yeah smart house like
now it's like that's actually a dumb
house it was like Pat is nothing
compared to Siri right but I had
forgotten really the aside from that
they were exchange students living
together I forgot the premise of the
movie where it's like said in 1977 where
this like Crysis apartheid in South
Africa is happening right I didn't
realize like the political context
surrounding it and then I also must have
forgotten that's a true story of course
I also must have forgotten to me which
was the most shocking moment of the
entire movie is that they see the n-word
twice on Disney Channel there's no way
that that played like during our time
but like they that's the movie that was
made it was made for writing I said I
honestly couldn't believe it I was
really shocked they went there they went
like you know it was a few times when I
was watching I was like wow they're
there going there they're going there I
mean that girl Mari who came from South
Africa like she was out of control
and she was insane and like when she
hopped off the plane and she thought
that the people picking her up was like
with like the staff and she like ordered
them to go get her bags like my jaw hit
the floor but you know what I feel like
it's actually it was a perfect movie to
watch because I think it hits on exactly
what we've been saying like even though
that carl mauri it was like cringy and
stuff like she wasn't evil she was just
like a victim of circumstance like
that's just how she was raised and it's
like it was like I almost felt bad for
her yeah and also it I mean the here the
best character in the movie is the mom
mom agreed she's fabulous and like she's
not giving up on anyone and like I feel
like for maybe Piper and the congressman
when they met Mari they would have just
sent her packing like this girl is a
lost cause but the mother really like
recognized that you know she's merely a
victim but exactly I wouldn't go that
far but
but like she's just a kid you know and
she gives her the greats like she
doesn't just cancel her she no she gives
her the benefit of the doubt she's like
we're gonna show you like that you're
wrong about some of the things that you
think and that you think that you know
and she's completely right about that
yeah totally no I 100% agree that the
mom was the most fabulous character she
was just like warm and inviting and
gracious and the congressman was all
about business and you can really have
time to invest in Maury which I
understand no he was busy but then that
pivotal scene with the books and he's
just like being such a dad yeah and it
was so cute and by the way that book
roots sounds really good they were sort
of like good books recommendations in
the movie the whole movie just felt so
timing I couldn't believe is it Disney
Channel movie I watched it not realizing
was a true story and at the end they
talked about the real congressman so I
did some research
Piper really this is the story of
Piper's a part of her life I had no idea
that it was a true story which is even
better which is so crazy and I always
say like part of the reason I loved the
movies that we've been watching during
trust movie of the week is like if a
movie ends with like black and white
text like that is this true benchmark of
a fabulous movie and it wasn't expecting
to see text on a decom no but when it
all said in that it was real like I knew
the apartheid like that was obviously
real I thought it was just like a
creative take on how to explain like
apartheid to kids but it really was a
true story and like I was shook yeah I
was really shocked I thought it was so
so good I really hope that you guys
watched it along with us because and I
was a powerful I hope if you have kids
or younger siblings like it really is
very accessible like I feel like it was
so well done
but yes by the way like there were a few
moments when I'm like did she really
just say that like when they were still
in South Africa and flora was talking
about flora but the housekeeper was
talking about the bird and she was like
it was like why can't people be like
that and then Morey was like because
they're birds not people the things you
say sometimes flora like so [ __ ]
nasty so nasty and so rude like Morey
I'm sorry I don't know how to pronounce
her name Mari Mari like she really
needed a reality check and like the
movie couldn't have come at a better
time for her no it couldn't have in like
when she comes home and she has the flag
sewn into her vest like beautiful and
flora knew that like this trip changed
everything for her yeah flora was the
only one who knew
was about to happen because like she
knew that she recognized the
congressman's name yeah it was a really
really good movie I loved it and like
parts of it were like honestly like
really uncomfortable yeah but I think
that's a benchmark of a good movie when
talking about racism yeah it's it's
gonna get uncomfortable it's gonna get
uncomfortable it was it was like it was
fabulous it was really really good I was
really so impressed impressed and
surprised cuz I I don't remember it
being like such like the historical
context everything about it was so well
done and totally great I mean it was
meant to be in the 70s and I don't know
when it was actually filmed but it was
housing mm mm it was at points like the
acting was so bad and it was very like
school after-school special like PSA
like it was cringy at times like with
some of the outfits and like the movie
montage of them in the mall dancing yeah
but I was able to look past that because
it was just a fabulous movie yeah and
it's on Disney Plus like it's so easy I
really encourage everyone to watch it if
you haven't watched it yet yes I agree
and I agreed there were some like you
know cringy Disney moment yeah but we
stand um
thus far what has been your favorite
movie that we watched oh great question
I think it has to be just mercy I was
gonna say there's others too like either
the one that I think impacted me the
most and like will forever have changed
how I see the world is just mercy but
entertainment lies like I loved hidden
figures Oh
I mean of course yeah of course that's
it's but I had already seen anyone into
right I probably would have said that
but that's just like in my catalog of
favorite movies ever
um and then with our next movie I think
that I think actually I've seen this
movie like maybe 20 years ago
I don't know if I've seen if I saw it it
was at a time when I was I too young to
remember what I watching so it will be
like I'm watching a new movie right
we're gonna watch Remember the Titans
which I'm excited about it's a nice
football themed movie so maybe your
husband's will want to watch it with you
if you have a husband um and that's all
she wrote that's all right II wrote yeah
her hands tired I guess it'd take Monday
and I feel that some type of way well
I'm gonna go get tested for Kovan
antibodies like everyone cross your
fingers and just like pray that I have
them I mean
thank you and that's all she right thank
you guys so much for listening to the
morning Tosa Milania morning show where
we go live Monday through Friday 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time oh wait no sorry um
whatever you know what happens we need
to rewrite that okay thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
the Millennial morning show where we
give you a show sometimes okay I got it
I got it thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning shows the
Millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toes every day
Monday through Friday we're also
available as a podcast a Friday on
YouTube we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcasts can be found
at Spotify iTunes stitcher Public Radio
I heard when you cast lots all the
places where ever you listen to podcast
find us the morning toast and please
leave a five star view about our
beautiful stunning and smart we are
thank you to everyone who tagged me on
your Instagram stories over the weekend
celebrating my birthday by watching my
comedy special that was really beautiful
of you Claudia that's beautiful the
special is available for purchase or
streaming on so many platform do
yourself a favor give yourself the gift
of Disgrace queen like I'll just turn
your frown upside down if you go to my
Instagram ones curly ones hey if you go
to my Instagram there's a highlight
called disgraced Queen and has links to
all the places you could buy it rented
stream it the comedy album or the video
and I hope you guys enjoy it and thank
you so much for all the kind words so
far it really it truly like nothing
feels as good and when someone
compliments your comedy and you know
what when people like dis your comedy it
really doesn't hurt
yeah cuz it's like cherry Stein bow says
comedy is more personal than food which
took me a few years to understand but
now that I do a minim reference it all
the time no it's so true and like
honestly like someone like wrote me a
nasty tweet like this special was so
dumb like really like like saying was so
offensive which is so crazy because like
my comedy is literally like the least
offensive stuff ever and I was like you
know what it really it did bother me
where's like criticism usually like
literally like kills me I was like
that's fine but if you're like funny and
cool and like normal you'll love the
special so don't worry about it okay
well we shall see you tomorrow if you're
looking for more content right now
you're like dang that show was short I
miss my girls day I'm so upset
dang flobbit head over at patreon.com
slash good morning toast we have tons of
content I was even thinking of like some
of the videos we've done in the past
like there's so much stuff there a year
ago this month I did
I am closet revamp with imagine they've
done like literally some people said it
was our favorite Visio video you can
learn how to fold a pair of underwear
just like really fabulous content we
have things you need to know every
steamy home tour we're gonna do the
chili cook-off this month I hope this is
aware he's prepared and he's ready and
gearing up yeah he's ready I mean he's
been talking smack pretty much all week
damn damn okay well anyways there's so
much content over there so head over
enjoy patreon.com slash the morning
toast and we shall see you tomorrow
goodbye goodbye
[Music]